We love to be the test dummies, here at the desk,
because people write into the show
and suggest things to us
that we should try and give a review on it.
And today, we're gonna be doing a thing
we love to do called Drew's Reviews.
(audience cheers)
(fanfare tingles)
(audience applauds)
Okay.
This is fun.
So the submission comes from Sammy Mozilio.
Okay. So Ross, what is this?
Okay, so these are the latest jelly beans
on the block, just in time for your Easter basket.
It's Brach's new, Late Night Taco Truck jelly bean.
(audience exclaim)
What?
And here's what's on the menu.
If you look here, we have margarita,
we have churro, salsa, guacamole, horchata, and beef taco.
(audience exclaim)
Okay.
Are you gonna try 'em?
I'm gonna start with the guacamole.
Okay, I'm gonna go with you here.
That's how I start eating the dip. (lips smacking)
Mm. Sort of.
More like "chocamole".
Yeah.
Okay, what about, I'm doing salsa.
Oh, hoo-hooey.
Oh. Whoa, whoa.
(audience laughs)
Oh, I'm doing beef taco and it is, um
it's beefy.
Oh.
(audience laughs)
I'm gonna do beef taco, try a salsa.
This is beef.
(audience laughs)
Whoa, on the salsa!
Right?
What is in there?
The beef is...
Where is the beef? (clears throat)
(audience laughs)
And then let's do, I'm gonna do churro,
'cause that seems safe.
I'm gonna wash it down with horchata and a margarita.
(audience laughs)
Oh yeah.
I'll take a margarita too.
'Cause the margarita just taste like a jelly bean.
(audience applauds)
That was a journey too.
Complete with cocktail.
Yeah.
You had the whole enchilada, right here.
That's what I'm talkin' about!
Yes!
(both laugh)
(audience applauds)
Yes.
All right, Rossy,
What's your star rating review for this?
Okay, I'm (garbles) I'm...
Okay, I like the concept,
but I'm gonna give the execution
about four outta five stars, okay?
Just 'cause that salsa was groaty.
Um, (chuckles)
my favorite is the horchata.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
I give the horchata five stars.
And the salsa, like, one star
and horchata wins.
I'm here for the margarita.
You know what it'd go nice with?
A margarita. (laughs)
Yes, it would.
Well, please give us your (swallows)
questions on things that we should review.
Write into the show at thedrewbarrymoreshow.com.
We love trying the things you ask us to.
And we'll try just about anything, right?
We really will.
(bright music)